This episode is sponsored by Blinkist.
Blinkist puts all the need to know information
from thousands of nonfiction books and condenses
them down into just 15 minutes, and you can
go to blinkist.com/microcosmos to learn more.
Hi, it’s me, Deboki, back on the Cnidarian
beat.
Last time I was here, we explored the terrifying
world of a hydra’s tentacles.
Today, I’m here to talk about one of their
relatives, the starlet sea anemone, also known
as Nematostella vectensis.
I didn’t know that I’ve spent my entire
life mispronouncing “anemone” as “anenome”
until I began learning about the starlet sea
anemone.
And so, I will often be referring to them
as Nematostella throughout this episode.
I hope you understand.
I can’t fault the starlet sea anemone for
its name though.
After all, I have a name that often involves
correcting other’s pronunciation.
And there’s more to the Nematostella’s
life that I feel kinship with, but to get
there, I need to start with a question.
When you look at the starlet sea anemone,
where do you think it’s from?
The water, sure.
But water is vast, vaster than land, and it
has its own boundaries and geography.
So, like, where do you think it’s really
from?
We can tell you where this particular individual
is from.
A lab at the University of Vienna, where it
lived until a scientist named Sanjay sent
one of his samples to James—our master of
microscopes—so that he, and we, could look at them.
So thank you, Sanjay.
There are a lot of nematostellas in labs around
the world.
Their bodies and reproduction are simple,
providing us with a means to explore the questions
and secrets behind how patterns and layers
form in bodies across nature.
But before the nematostella ended up in labs,
they—or one of their forebears—must have
come from somewhere.
But where?
The answer should be simple.
In 1935, the biologist Thomas Alan Stephenson
gathered twenty years worth of work into a
two-volume monograph titled “The British
Sea Anemones”.
In there lies the first recorded description
of the starlet sea anemone, which had been
found in a brackish pond on the Isle of Wight
.
Compared to the organisms we usually focus
on, the nematostella is quite large, growing
several millimeters in height.
But for someone wading through a pond, it’d
be easy to overlook.
It’s small, translucent, and a burrower,
digging itself into mud and letting its tentacles
spill out onto the visible surface.
But difficult as the nematostella is to spot,
researchers became concerned in the 1980s
when their counts of the starlet sea anemone
in England began to dwindle.
In 1983, the nematostella was classified as
a vulnerable species to protect it from extinction.
This is sadly not an uncommon tale when it
comes to our interactions with wildlife, and
so it’s tempting to leave it here,
to allow the starlet sea anemone to become
yet another cautionary tale of our environmental
misdeeds.
And yet.
While the species was first described in Britain,
it has been found in other parts of the world
too, particularly on both the Atlantic and
Pacific coasts of North America.
And when scientists counted, there seemed
to be plenty of nematostella in these other regions.
But there were some weird quirks to these
different populations.
The English Nematostella population seemed
to be completely void of males, like an underwater Themiscyra.
Meanwhile, the population in Nova Scotia seemed
to be entirely male.
And there didn’t seem to be any environmental
explanation for why some populations might
be different from the others.
So what caused these nematostella to take
up at such different locations, and in such
different ways?
Boats.
For centuries , boats have been traveling
the world, taking cargo and passengers alike.
And with them have travelled even smaller
passengers, including—most likely—the nematostella.
After all, it’s small and hardy, able to
survive journeys through the different temperatures
and salinities.
And most importantly for the traveling nematostella,
it can reproduce asexually, dividing to form
more versions of itself.
This would explain why we might find populations
of the starlet sea anemone that are entirely
female or entirely male.
That’s just the one that showed up first,
the one that made its way to a new home and
then filled it with its own clones.
Our genes are a map of our ancestor’s lives,
and in the case of the nematostella, they’ve
helped scientists chart the path the organism
likely took.
The nematostella in Britain, for example,
have very little genetic diversity compared
to their New England counterparts, suggesting
that the British ones are a more recent transplant.
And using inferences like that, scientists
have piece together a story where nematostella
made its way from the western Atlantic (or,
maybe less confusingly, the east coast of
North America), and then travelled the world
from there.
So the nematostella is not native to Britain.
It’s a recent arrival, early in forming
its identity.
But when it comes to asking where the starlet
sea anemone is from, I’ll be straightforward:
it’s hard not to project a little as someone
who has been asked that question in its many
forms before, and as someone whose home is
an amalgamation of the immediate places I’ve
lived in, and a city on the other side of
the world where I didn’t.
Even learning about how the genetic uniformity
of certain populations provides us snapshots
of the anemone’s journey feels familiar.
Immigration and diasporas are complex and
nuanced, so there’s no way to generalize
from my own experience.
But an idea that I heard once and that has
stuck with me when I understand my Indian
American experience is this notion that first
and second generations like me tend to carry
our family’s country of origin with us from
a certain point of time, so that the traditions
and rituals we choose to maintain in this
new home tie us together while also inevitably dating us.
Often, when you’re a first or second generation
immigrant in America, your journey is framed
in terms of tension: of a tension between
who claims you, and who you claim.
I hate thinking in these terms, even when
it feels true because I’ve come to realize
that as much as these claims are impactful,
they can also be arbitrary, shifting with
the currents and climate and location.
If it’s a question of where I belong, the
answer will always be conditional, and that’s frustrating.
Defining the Nematostella’s origins is conditional
as well, dependent upon the asker’s aims.
But the Nematostella is not an immigrant,
and I have no desire to compare the entirety
of the immigrant experience and its human
realities to an anemone.
As a question of conservation though, the
nematostella’s origins become significant.
In England, where our understanding of the
species originated, the populations are dwindling.
But the efforts to protect it are built more
on earlier assumptions that the nematostella
is a native species, which we know now it
is not.
But we also know that whenever the nematostella
arrived at its new home, it took to it, and
without causing further harm to its local
ecology.
In the early 2000s, scientists argued that
while we may not need to introduce populations
of nematostella to its British locations,
it is still worth protecting the ones that
are already there.
So where is the nematostella from?
Well, it depends.
And this time, I find that kind of beautiful.
Thank you for coming on this journey with
us as we explore the unseen world that surrounds us.
And we’d like to thank Blinkist for sponsoring
today’s episode.
These days it can be hard to remember that
your phone can be used for productive purposes.
It’s extremely easy to find yourself scrolling
in one app, only to close that one and start
scrolling in another, and suddenly, without
even noticing it, you find that you’re back
in that first app again?!
How did that happen?
Well, Blinkist is here to help you use your
time more effectively.
Blinkist is an app that takes the best insights
and need-to-know information from over 3,000
nonfiction books and condenses them down into
just 15 minutes that you can read or listen to.
It can be hard to find the time to sit down
and learn more, but with Blinkist you can
explore their massive library of books in
categories like self-help, business, science, and history.
We’re often showing you microbes that look
like tiny specks on your screen, but once
you check out Carl Sagan’s “Cosmos”
on Blinkist and try to wrap your head around
how big the universe that we live in actually
is, you’ll start to look at our planet as
if it is just a tiny speck within another
tiny speck.
And if you’re one of the first 100 people
to sign up today at Blinkist.com/microcosmos,
you can get free unlimited access for 7 days
and you’ll also get 25% off if you decide
to get a full membership.
Click the link in the description to start
your free 7-day trial.
The names on the screen, those are our Patreon
patrons.
And we’d like to thank each and every one
of you who has chosen to support this channel.
And if you’d like to become one of those
people, you can go to patreon.com/journeytomicro.
If you want to see more from our Master of
Microscopes James Weiss, you can check out
Jam & Germs on Instagram or also on TikTok.
And if you want to see more from us, there
is always a subscribe button somewhere nearby.